[Music]  oh yeah guys check this out everyone did  this back in like  middle school and high school that's how  you know it's serious no it's not you  know has style you guys need something  to distinguish you though  as like opposing forces  yeah no no what if we do like colors  like what if i give you a different  color yeah let's do that yeah yeah  headbands  all right so demon united sent us a  bunch of sweet stunt armor bmx armored  dirt bike armor you name it so we  decided to put it all on and have a  sweet jousting session on razer scooters  oh  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  oh  [Laughter]  my camera stopped buffering like a frame  before it  so big thanks to demon united check out  this stuff on demon united.com they got  a shop with all these sweet pads  and see how well it holds up  [Music]  [Music]  it was awesome